[Musique]
toute la journée derrière moi et toute
la nuit sur le dos
en la chaleur dans le froid il me pousse
sur les tréteaux leur diana leur récital
j'en ai vraiment flow
et à tous ses bourreaux je souhaite le
supplice du pal
[Musique]
je n'en fais plus s'ils vont me tuer
tous ces exploits
[Musique]
circonstances et puis mon imprésario il
s'enrichit sur mon dos il dit non pas
qu'on va chanter au palmarès ça tu feras
de la promotion mais il prend 90 pour ça
aussi les filles qui jette sur moi celle
qui escaladent la toile celle qui disait
moi et moi oh comme je m'en mords le
chinois enfin ce qu'il en reste
[Musique]
ce sont les
tuer
oui
je vais créer
merci et pitié de l'artiste mais le pire
c'est que mon parolier non seulement il
est fou à lier il voulait me faire
chanter tu eu des histoires d'obsédé je
ne dors plus je ne mange plus j'ai
maigri je suis aigri suis malade et
cetera je suis pas vieux mais j'en veux
plus
[Musique]
je m'en fais pas ils vont me tuer
oui
chérie
[Musique]
c'est moi
v
et des mois sans peinture
[Musique]
oui
je
suis
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]